في السعوديه دشنت وزاره الشؤون البلديه
والقرويه والاسكان مع رودستيكس الرياض
العقاري 2023 الذي يعد اهم ملتقى سنوي
لصنع القرار في القطاع العقاري والاستثمار
الاسكاني والتمويلي وشهد المعرض الذي من
المقرر ان يستمر حتى العاشر من الشهر
الجاري اطلاق اربعه صناديق عقاريه بقيمه
اجماليه تجاوزت اربعه مليارات ريال بهدف
توفير اكثر من 4000 وحده سكنيه في كل من
الرياض والمدينه المنوره على مساحه تتجاوز
مليون متر مربع
بحضور اكثر من 100 منظمه دوليه واقليميه
انطلقت اعمال مؤتمر مستقبل منظمات التربيه
والثقافه والعلوم تحت شعار مع النحو
التغيير في القرن ال 21 في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياضه و يهدف المؤتمر الذي
تنظمه المنظمه العربيه للتربيه والثقافه
والعلوم الالكسو واللجنه الوطنيه السعوديه
للتربيه والثقافه والعلوم الى تعزيز
التعاون والاستدامه بين المنظمات الدوليه
اضافه الى بناء منصه عالميه حاضنه
للمنظمات الدوليه
ومن الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الواحد الحميد اهلا بك عبد الواحد يعني
بدات فعاليات المؤتمر ماذا في جلسات اليوم
ومن هم ابرز المتحدثين
اهلا وسهلا نعم نحن في اليوم الاول من هذا
المؤتمر الذي يضم اكثر من 65 متحدثا اضافه
الى ذلك اكثر من 100 منظمه تشارك في هذا
المؤتمر الذي يقام لاول مره اليوم الاول
يضم عديد من الجلسات وحلقات النقاش التي
تتناول موضوعات مختلفه متعلقه
بالمحاور الرئيسيه لهذا المؤتمر الذي يقام
على مدار يومين طبعا في هذا المؤتمر هناك
العديد من خبراء الدوليين الذين يشاركون
في جلسات هذا المؤتمر على مدار اليوم
لنتحدث اكثر حول تفاصيل هذا المؤتمر ينضم
الينا الاستاذ هاني المقبل وهو رئيس
المجلس التنفيذي للاليكسو اهلا وسهلا بك
استاذ هاني نريد ان نعرف يعني ما هي
المخرجات المتوقعه من هذا المؤتمر
اول شيء شكرا القاعده العربيه خلنا نتكلم
اليوم انه التاريخ اليوم سجل اعتباره من
ثمانيه مارس 2023 هذه هي اول تجمع يجمع
المنظمات الدوليه والاقليميه المهتمه
بالتربيه الثقافه العلوم لاكثر من خمسين
عاما لم تشتمها منظمات تحت مظله واحده
لمناقشه سبل مستقبل توجهاتها اليوم بدات
هذا الحراك وهذا التواصل واتوقع ان
مخرجاتها اكثر كثير مما توقع هناك مقوله
انجليزيه تقول بان الحوارات الصحيه ده
عاده تنتج منتجات عظيمه اليوم ما شاهدناه
من تقارب الافكار والرؤى المشتركه بين
المنظمات والتوجهاتها يعطينا امل بان
المستقبل في التنسيق والتعاون والتكامل
سيكون اكبر بكثير من مكان في السابق اليوم
هذه المنظمات تخدم الدول وتخدم الافراد
لكن عملها في السابق كان احادي الاطراف
لكن اليوم هو سينتقل يكون ثنائي بتنسيق
مشترك وتعاون ولا يمكن ان تتحقق رؤيه
دوليه مشتركه ما لم يكون هناك تواصل
وتنسيق وتواصل ثاني خبراء يعني يشاركون في
هذا المؤتمر الذي يقام لاول مره على
الاطلاق ماذا تتوقعون مستقبلا في هذا
الاطار
خلني اتكلم بس ان اليوم هذه مبادره من
المنظمه العربيه
السعوديه وافقت مشكوره باستضافه كريمه على
استضافه هذا المؤتمر
كيف يتحول هذا المؤتمر الى حوار عملي في
المستقبل بناء على الحراك والنقاش اللي تم
منظمات سيعطي امل كبير في فتح قنوات كثيره
القنوات لا يمكن تتحقق وكلن يعمل في مكتبه
اليوم اكثر من 100 منظمه موجوده في الرياض
اكثر من 70 متحدث من مختلف من سبع قطاعات
تقريبا كلها تتكلم على المستقبل مستقبل لا
يعني
الحديث عن التفاصيل وانهم يعني الحديث عن
الفرس اليوم هناك فرص كبيره جدا موجوده في
التعاون وفي الاخير ما يخدم البشريه هو ما
سينتج عن هذه العلاقات والتواصل والشراكات
بين هذه المنظمات شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه التفاصيل استاذ هاني المقبل على كل
هذه التفاصيل التي زودنا بها متعلقه
بالمؤتمر طبعا المؤتمر راويه يستمر على
مدار يومين نحن في اليوم الاول اليوم
الثاني سوف يعني يكون هناك العديد من
الجلسات
لهذا المؤتمر